Apple you have heard of them you're
probably uh watching this on some sort
of Apple device either macbook or an
iPhone or an iPad or something else uh
they sold 31.2 million iphones last
quarter but believe it or not they're
not doing that well uh let's take a look
at some numbers so this is apple sales
and profit and you can see uh that their
profit has fallen twenty-two percent in
the past quarter their stock has dropped
forty percent in the last 10 months that
that seems completely crazy to me uh and
in the current quarter they're expected
to underperform wall street expectations
and uh i think this leads to a lot of
interesting stuff because is this about
just sort of general technology fatigue
we've definitely had a theme in this
episode i didn't even intend on it being
that way uh is this general technology
fatigue is there something about apple
that we're all starting to get a little
tired of you know they have this new
commercial now we're uh California made
in california and a warm and fuzzy yes
oh no does a main accompanies his design
made it right because they don't ever
have right because they don't say made
in China yes a design in California it
feels very lovely Lea lays back and
Steve Jobs garage with him that's the
kind of vibe they're trying to get you
to reconnect to yeah so are we having a
little apple fatigue right now that this
stuff we all have all of this stuff now
and that maybe they're becoming you know
they did that famous 1984 commercial way
back way kinda takes down Microsoft but
now they've become the model it I'm I'm
willing to say I don't know where this
is coming from because I don't see any
fatigue amongst anybody I mean they may
get sick of the products at times but
they don't stop buying it I don't see
anything happening i'm alright it's cool
to say you're sick of it yeah you have
an iphone i assume no you don't i'm
gonna wrestle i'm one of those yeah
woody guy I'm gonna Android I'm I'm a
the galaxy you wow I wish they would
have told me and then insane of the
fabric yeah
an easy but my girlfriend has the exact
opposite she has the ipad and she has
all happy actually has the macbook and
all this absolute she puts that side so
still in the house so still permeating
the the finance is somewhere in the
house phone all right it works that way
so everyone has it connected with it in
some way but as we were speaking about
earlier what are you gonna go to the
next that is just as much of a pain in
your ass is the one before and each m
has their pluses and minuses yes I don't
know how this is going down again I'm
stumped yeah I think it's two things I
think there is a little bit of apple
fatigue I think we have lost connection
to the brand because Steve Jobs died but
I also think this is a bunch of Wall
Street [ __ ] this is all this is to
me this is real is that that's why these
are all right here are those numbers of
the Year seven billion dollars in
profits isn't enough for all streets
right this is the endless cancer growth
that that Wall Street ones it's about
endless growth it's about endless
progress nothing on the planet of the
natural world has endless growth except
for cancer and Wall Street and we have
not we have no concept in our economy
anymore about limitations that if it
doesn't keep growing that if it's
plateauing it's all a fear it's like
this company is clearly going through
changes yes I think there is some
general fatigue about like what is the
you know when the ipod came out it was
like all gotta have that iphone gotta
have that i pick up yes they're there to
figuring it out what's gonna be the next
iteration in all of this but this is
Wall Street [ __ ] this is the stuff i
hate about our economy that it's run by
you know your your earnings each each
quarter right because there's we live
and die by these things right and
they're saying that they sold 31.2
million iphones in the quarter that's an
incredible amount i think it might be
their best quarter ever and yet it's
still because of the wall street numbers
it still makes it seem like something
right yeah it it's a skewed and it's at
you know eschewed standards and we've
all bought into oh we gotta hear that
the wall street numbers the dow jones
numbers today and it's like this for the
most part is meaningless to ninety nine
percent of us this transition does it
transcend to consumers now to hear these
numbers and say oh i love apple products
right i need to go by i need to make
sure they stay
maybe maybe yeah it's really messed up
person if they're like oh man apple and
yeah but you think like is the mom and
pop shop down the street from where you
grew up you like let's support our mom
and pop shops they can stay afloat we
think that about the souper corporation
I have a little a little other version
of that which is we do try to find
meaning in these numbers because we
don't really are connected to them so we
think oh maybe Apple isn't doing as well
and and and so I think maybe some people
then may pull back from the brand a
little bit to see like well maybe
they're not the coolest thing out there
let's see what's gonna happen you know
Google's got this you know all these
other weird shits coming out I do think
it's possible they're victim of their
own success in this way I actually got a
new macbook air whatever a couple months
ago when I went into the store you know
they greet you immediately and the guy i
knew i was gonna get one it was very
obvious from the initial I wasn't you're
not haggling over price at Apple you're
taking it and that's it but I felt that
the guy was so dismissive like they know
you're walking in to buy it like there
so they think they're so cool like yet
you want this thing let's just do this
you know and it's like maybe they
actually are suffering from their own
success I've had some bad service there
and we've we've gotten some response
from some managers because of that but
the thing is at Christmas time my
husband and I went to the mall and there
was the apple store and then there was a
new internet explorer store and they
wear the t-shirts like the apple store
they had designed it just like the apple
store there were two people customers in
the internet explorer store 25 guys
working there women working there we go
bought you couldn't even get near the
apple store there was a line to get in
and it was like okay no matter what
Apple's fine Apple's doing fine they're
doing oh yeah yeah now how do we get you
to get on Apple cuz they need you man
they may be okay this is yeah these
these are tweet about as well like every
I just have my things about iphone ipad
users first of all your phone is never
charged every time you come to anyone's
house there's barbecued as a partner
does anyone have an episode have a
charger oh I lost my charger oh no I
left in the car I said well if it's
never charged bring it with you I'm
Vicky this is hate when you get ya
wow great just let it let it out but I
cannon and I was one of other co-workers
he got his iphone dropped at the corner
hit the floor it was a carpeted store
whole screenshot is the screen made of
like the thinnest thin glass I don't get
it i've seen thirty percent of people
with iphones have a cracked screen yeah
well you'd have to talk to the
manufacturers in china because it's only
designed in California design the paper
thin glass here but then they created
yeah